-You've been here a fair amount
throughout the Trump presidency.
We're now coming up on a year.
Are you --
It's felt longer than a year,
but based on where we are now
and where we were a year ago,
is this what you expected,
and is there anything
that you didn't expect?
-Every day that has happened in
the last year, I didn't expect.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
I think I expected --
In your monologue
or "A Closer Look,"
you talked about the
55 minutes of Trump
negotiating immigration.
-Yeah.
-However, obviously not
well-versed on every issue,
but in there --
and, you know, breathing.
-Yeah. Talking words.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I think
I expected more of that...
-Uh-huh.
-...and less of the
just bedlam and chaos
that has really marked the year.
-We talked -- You mentioned
the Michael Wolff book
and the anger
that's coming out
of the Trump White House
about it.
You think, to some degree,
that speaks to the vanity
of the Trump White House.
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, I think Michael Wolff
very clearly -- and I think
he's been pretty open about it.
Early on, he wrote
a vaguely flattering piece
about President Trump.
More than it being flattering,
it had a nice picture...
-Yeah.
-...on the cover
of "The Hollywood Reporter."
-It was a nice picture.
-It was a very nice picture and
he apparently really liked it.
-Yeah. He likes ones
with more pictures.
[ Laughter ]
-And then he did an early
interview with Steve Bannon
that was offensively
just handing him
the microphone and talking
at a time when I think a lot
of people were really worried
about Steve Bannon and what
ideas he was gonna bring in.
But it was all what's called,
in my business, beat-sweetening.
He was sweetening the beat.
He was gaining their trust,
and they fell for it.
And, look, this is a guy who
has a reputation for doing this
and making a lot of money and
being very successful doing it,
flattering his way into a story,
doing his particular
kind of journalism,
and leaving a lot
of crying people behind him.
-You know,
Bannon gets a lot of credit
for being sort of
a crazy genius
who figured out all these things
and yet makes
a mistake like this.
Is it just more likely
that there was not
a lot of genius going on?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I don't think I've ever
called him a creative genius.
-Yeah.
-But I think that --
I think that,
first of all, where --
Look, I wasn't there for a lot
of it, or for any of it, really.
But I think
that certain journalists,
when they say something's off
the record, they really mean it.
They think it's --
You know, you can honor it.
And certain journalists, it
doesn't mean anything to them.
And they're happy
to burn sources
and run away from the story.
I mean, and run away
after the story is done,
and it seems as though
he did that a bunch of times.
So, I mean, I don't --
You know, Bannon's not denying
that he said
these things in the book.
And I can't believe
he would've said them
thinking they were
gonna be in the book.
-Right.
It is pretty crazy.
And the interesting thing is,
there is a parallel,
because I feel
as though Donald Trump
sort of burned a lot of people
on his way to the White House,
and then, I think
he would justify it by saying,
"I got to the White House,"
whereas Michael Wolff
did the same,
and I think
he would justify it by being,
"I'm the number-one book
on Amazon."
-There is
a poetic justice to it...
-Yeah.
-..that this is the book so far
that defines
the Trump presidency
with somebody who has --
Yeah, who has just
upended all standards.
And yet,
we in the media, journalists,
are supposed
to uphold standards.
-Yeah.
-We're not supposed to
lower them just according to --
I mean, you know.
If I responded to --
This is the world we're in.
If I responded
to President Trump
the way that
he writes about journalists,
I mean, calling me
a flunky or whatever,
you would be like, "Oh,
I can't believe Jake did that."
-Yeah.
-You would --
You would be disappointed.
-I'm glad you
hold the standard up.
-You'd be like, "Well,
I wish he hadn't done that.
I wish he hadn't --"
The President did it!
The President --
The President did it.
But we are expected
to uphold these standards.
So, I mean, that's why I'm not,
you know, reading the book
on-air as gospel.
We have
to be skeptical about it.
-The real standard
in your family --
-Oh, yeah.
-No offense to you.
Your daughter, last October,
got an op-ed published
in the "New York Times."
-She's 10.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But, this is true
that she got an op-ed,
and it's called --
by the way, she did not hide
that she was 10.
The op-ed title is "I'm 10."
[ Laughter ]
"And I Want Girls
to Raise Their Hand."
And this is a true story.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Your daughter came up
with her own Girl Scout badge.
-My kids are amazing,
Jack, who's 8,
and Alice, who's 10.
And Alice came home
from school and said,
"The girls
don't raise their hands.
The boys raise their hands."
And she talked about it
with my wife, her mom.
with her Girl Scout troop,
and they came up with this badge
to encourage girls
to raise their hands.
You have to pledge to do it
and get three other girls
to do it.
She came up with the badge,
and when the badge came out,
I was very proud,
and I put it out there.
It was also right in the middle
of the #MeToo movement,
and it seemed like it's great.
Because she wasn't blaming
anybody for anything.
She was saying, "We need
to be in charge of this."
-Yep.
-And then, I tweeted it,
and somebody
from the "New York Times,"
a nice woman named
Bari Weiss reached out and said,
"Would your daughter want
to write an op-ed for us,"
and she did it.
And honestly, these --
Like, she's like,
"Oh, that's cool."
She doesn't know.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Have you ever been asked
to write an op-ed
in "The New York Times"?
-Um, I've had a few in there,
but never --
[ Laughter ]
It's more like
I've begged to get them in.
-Yeah.
-I've never been solicited.
-Right, right.
-Actually, that's not true.
They asked me
to write something,
and then they killed it.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Did she ever go over
and be like,
"Hey, Dad, that's all right.
Sometimes you win,
sometimes you lose"?
[ Laughter ]
Well, you have
an incredible family.
I'm always happy to see them,
as well.
And thank you so much
for being here.